HE'LL SPEAK ABOUT IT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A FEW MOMENTS.
WE BEGIN THOUGH TONIGHT IN A
SIMILAR VEIN WITH A PICTURE OF
CONTEMPT IN MANY FORMS.
CONTEMPT FOR CONGRESS AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY WE GRANTED TO
INVESTIGATE MATTERS TO NATIONAL
IMPORTANCE.
CONTEMPT FOR THE LAW AND
CONTEMPT FOR DEMOCRACY, WHICH
TOOK A BLOW WHEN THE BUILDING
YOU SEE THERE WAS ATTACKED.
WE GOT ANOTHER REMINDER OF IT
LATE TODAY.
VIDEO OF THE BRUTAL ASSAULT ON A
D.C. POLICE OFFICER WHO YOU'LL
SEE HIGHLIGHTED.
HE'S DRAGGED OUT OF THE BUILDING
BY THE MOB AND THE USUAL
WARNINGS APPLY THAT SOME MIGHT
WANT TO LOOK AWAY FOR A FEW
MOMENTS.
MOB OF PEOPLE ATTACKING A POLICE
OFFICER.
HE AND ABOUT 140 OTHERS WERE
HURT.
SEVERAL LATER DIED BY SUICIDE.
THE PEOPLE THEY WERE PROTECTING
OF BOTH PARTIES WERE THREATENED,
SOME WITH DEATH, AS THEY CARRIED
OUT THEIR DUTY TO WITHHOLD
RESULTS OF A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
CONTEMPT FOR THAT, ALL OF IT, IS
PERSONIFIED BY STEVE BANNON.
WHEN LAST WE HEARD HE WAS BEING
PARDONED BY THAT SAME PRESIDENT
WHILE FACING CHARGES OF
SWINDLING DONORS WHO THOUGHT
THEIR MONEY WAS FUNDING THE
BORDER WALL.
PROSECUTORS SAY A LOT OF IT,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
WORTH, WAS SIPHONED OFF BY
BANNON HIMSELF AND USED TO COVER
PERSONAL EXPENSES.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT PARDONED
HIM EVEN THOUGH HE WAS ACCUSED
OF CONNING THE PRESIDENT'S
SUPPORTERS.
WHICH TELLS YOU SOMETHING ABOUT
WHAT HE THINKS ABOUT HIS
SUPPORTERS.
TODAY, INSTEAD OF SITTING FOR
DEPOSITION, HE DEFIED THE
COMMITTEE'S SUBPOENA.
THEY VOWED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT PROCEEDINGS.
IT ALSO POSTPONED DEPOSITIONS
FOR THREE OTHER SENIOR ALLIES OF
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND SAID IT
WOULD TAKE UP THE BANNON MATTER
NEXT TUESDAY.
THEIR NEXT STEP WOULD BE TO
BUILD A CRIMINAL CONTEMPT
REFERRAL WHICH WOULD BE SENT TO
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS.
KAITLYN COLLINS ASKED ABOUT IT
AT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
Z
>> IS IT THE PRESIDENT'S
POSITION THAT THOSE WHO DEFY
DEPOSITIONS SHOULD FACE
PROSECUTION FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> I KNOW THAT HAS BEEN RAISED
AS AN ISSUE, OF COURSE, BY WHAT
WE'VE SEEN HAPPEN IN CONGRESS.
IT'S THE PURVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
DETERMINE IF THERE WOULD BE
CRIMINAL REFERRAL, ANY CRIMINAL
DECISIONS SO THEY HANDLE
EXCLUSIVELY THOSE DECISIONS.
SO I'D POINT YOU TO THEM.
>> AS LEGAL ANALYSTS HAVE TOLD
US, WHAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DECIDES TO DO IS ANYBODY'S
GUESS.
IT IS HOWEVER, A DIFFERENT
INSTITUTION THAN IT WAS WHEN
STEVE BANNON AND OTHERS COULD
RUN ROUGH SHOT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT COULD KEEP HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL OUT OF IT.
IN THE CASE OF WILLIAM BARR
TRUST THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
DISTORT THE TRUTH ON HIS BEHALF
AS BARR DID WITH THE MUELLER
REPORT.
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING WHAT
BANNON WAS DOING LAST NIGHT, HE
WAS HEADLINING A RALLY FOR GLENN
YOUNGKIN.
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT PHONED IN
TO ENDORSE HIM AND SPREAD LIES
ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION OF
COURSE AT THE SAME TIME.
EVEN MORE TELLING AND OBSCENE
WAS THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THIS PARTICULAR FLAG.
>> I ALSO WANT TO INVITE KIM
FROM CHESAPEAKE.
SHE'S CARRYING AN AMERICAN FLAG
THAT WAS CARRIED AT THE PEACEFUL
RALLY WITH DONALD J. TRUMP ON
JANUARY 6th.
>> YOUNGKIN, WHO WAS HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE ENDORSEMENT, MADE
SURE TO STAY AWAY FROM THE
RALLY.
HE SAID THIS, QUOTE, I WASN'T
INVOLVED UNTIL I DON'T KNOW, BUT
IF THAT IS THE CASE, THEN WE
SHOULDN'T PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THAT FLAG.
AS FOR WHAT IT SYMBOLIZES TO
BANNON AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S FOLLOWERS, WE CAN'T
SAY.
IT'S NOT LIKE THAT WAS SOME
ZENNED OUT MOMENT.
IT WAS INCITEMENT AND LIES ABOUT
THE ELECTION.
>> THIS THE MOST CORRUPT
ELECTION IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
>> ALL WE ARE DEMANDING OF VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE IS THIS
AFTERNOON AT 1:00, HE LET THE
LEGISLATURES OF THE STATE LOOK
INTO THIS SO WE GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
>> AND WE FIGHT.
WE FIGHT LIKE HELL AND IF YOU
DON'T FIGHT LIKE HELL, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE A COUNTRY
ANYMORE.
>> LET'S HAVE TRIAL BY COMBAT.
>> TODAY IS THE DAY AMERICAN
PATRIOTS START TAKING DOWN NAMES
AND KICKING ASS.
>> SO WE'RE GOING TO, WE'RE
GOING TO WALK DOWN PENNSYLVANIA
AVENUE, I LOVE PENNSYLVANIA
AVENUE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO THE CAPITOL.
WE'RE GOING TO CHEER ON OUR
BRAVE SENATORS AND CONGRESSMEN
AND WOMEN AND WE'RE PROBABLY NOT
GOING TO BE CHEERING SO MUCH FOR
SOME OF THEM.
BECAUSE YOU'LL NEVER TAKE BACK
OUR COUNTRY WITH WEAKNESS.
>> SO IT BEGAN.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
BUT JUST IN CASE YOU'RE
WONDERING WHETHER THE ORGANIZERS
HAD AN IDEA OF WHERE THIS MIGHT
LEAD, YOU NOT ONLY NEED LISTEN
TO BANNON'S PODCAST THE DAY
BEFORE.
>> ALL HELL IS GOING TO BREAK
LOOSE TOMORROW.
JUST UNDERSTAND THIS.
ALL HELL IS GOING TO BREAK LOOSE
TOMORROW.
>> SO IS IT ANY WONDER THE
SELECT COMMITTEE WANTS TO TALK
TO HIM AND IS IT ANY WONDER THE
MAN WHO COULDN'T STOP TALKING
ABOUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF NEXT
DAY NO LONGER WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT IT?
WE'RE JOINED BY ONE OF TWO
REPUBLICANS ON THE COMMITTEE.
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
YOUR COLLEAGUE, CHAIRMAN VINNIE
T
THOMPSON, HAS NOT RULED OUT A
SUBPOENA FOR FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IS THAT REALLY REALISTIC, A
SUBPOENA FOR HIM OR VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE?
>> YEAH, I'M SURE, YOU KNOW, IT
IS REALISTIC.
I MEAN, WE'RE NOT GOING TO JUMP
TO DOING THAT IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THAT'S BIG.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
KNOW A LOT.
BUT I'M GOING TO TELL YOU, I
KNOW THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
WE'VE BEEN MEETING A LOT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE
ISSUES.
WE ARE DETERMINED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT HAPPENED.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE SEEING WITH
THE POTENTIAL CRIMINAL REFERRAL
BY STEVE, OF STEVE BANNON BY THE
COMMITTEE, HOPEFULLY IF PEOPLE
MISINTERPRET ANYTHING ELSE,
INTERPRET THIS.
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT THIS.
AND ANYBODY THAT IS EITHER BEING
SUBPOENAED NOW OR WILL BE IN THE
FUTURE THINK TWICE BEFORE YOU
REJECT A LAWFUL ORDER FROM
CONGRESS.
>> SO BUT IN TERMS OF MOVING
FORWARD TO HOLD BANNON IN
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT, THE COMMITTEE
IS GOING TO HOLD A BUSINESS
MEETING TUESDAY.
WHAT HAPPENS THERE AND WHAT ARE
THE NEXT STEPS AFTER THAT?
BECAUSE COULDN'T THIS JUST GET
TIED UP IN COURTS FOR, YOU KNOW,
AND RUN OUT THE CLOCK ON THIS
COMMITTEE?
>> YEAH, IT COULD.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS.
SO WE HAVE A BUSINESS MEETING.
WE REFER IT OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE.
IT GOES TO THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE.
WE EXPECT IT WOULD PASS THE
FLOOR AND THAT THEN IS THE
REFERRAL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
WE EXPECT THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL DO THEIR JOB AND
REFER THIS TO A GRAND JURY.
AND WE CERTAINLY HOPE THEY WILL.
BUT THAT WILL BE IN THE DOJ'S
HANDS.
NOW KEEP IN MIND REALLY FROM A
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE, A
SUBPOENA FROM CONGRESS IS SEEN
IN ESSENCE AS A SUBPOENA FROM A
COURT AND WE KNOW A LOT OF TIMES
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT IGNORE
SUBPOENAS FROM COURT AND THEY
ARE HELD IN CRIMINAL CONTEMPT
FOR DOING THAT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE.
WHAT WE'RE, YOU KNOW, A CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT REFERRAL IS NOTHING
FRANKLY CRAZY.
DOESN'T HAPPEN AS MUCH WITH
CONGRESS, BUT IT IS IN ESSENCE
WITHIN OUR POWER AND IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
AGAIN, ANYBODY THAT GETS A
SUBPOENA IN FUTURE, LOOK, ALL WE
WANT IS THE ANSWER.
IF YOU'RE RUNNING FROM
SOMETHING, I MEAN I THINK THAT
IN AND OF ITSELF SAYS SOMETHING,
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
TO KNOW THE TRUTH AND EVEN IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO KNOW THE
TRUTH TODAY, SOME FOLKS WANT TO
PUT THEIR HEAD IN THE SAND, WHAT
MATTERS MORE THAN ANYTHING IS IN